[Music]
avenges endgame has just received its
first test screening and the initial
reactions are creating a huge buzz on
the internet throughout this video I'll
be breaking down all the news from the
screenings as well as what it could mean
for the movie going ahead there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
to know anything about the film then I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to okay so the first thing to take
from the recent news as that endgame has
actually had bought test screenings all
with audience reaction and giving a huge
praise and staying that's one of the
best MCU movies ever made the film is
currently clocking in at 3 hours and
whilst there have been rumors of an
intermission being put in the film I
personally think that this will be
highly unlikely due to the lucky people
that got to see it apparently not
getting up to pee the Russo brothers
confirmed this was the case and when
speaking with Collider
they also said I think the studio is
down with what the best story is right
now we think the movie is playing well
and we've had great responses from our
test audiences and we're feeling very
good about where it is we're still doing
work to it we're not done with it again
this is a culmination film of 22 movies
it's a lot of storytelling to work into
it
emotion is an intrinsic part of that to
us when you have to tell a really
complicated story and you want strong
emotional moments with the characters it
just requires a certain amount of real
estate this one in particular feels like
three hours worth of real estate they
later went on to confirm that the film
is half way through the editing process
so it may slightly divert it from the
three hour runtime
however if like me you're excited for
the film you'll know that you want is
much movie as you can get also this week
we had a leaked image of the costumes
from the film after being mistakenly put
out by a popcorn company fans got the
first look at the quantum realm
bracelets that will most likely be used
for time travel as well as the Hulk in
his professor
get up this character from the comics
melds the minds of the Hulk and Bruce
Banner as one and definitely seems like
a likely step forward for the character
to go into a day after this image was
leaked we also got our first plot
synopsis on the film the plot synopsis
itself states a lot of extra information
too and highlights that the stakes are
going to be high and that the
consequences of the snap have been dire
the official synopsis reads after the
devastating events of Avengers infinity
war the universe is in ruins due to the
efforts of the mad Titan Thanos with the
help of the remaining allies the
Avengers must assemble once more in
order to undo that as his actions and
restore order to the universe once and
for all no matter what consequences may
be install this is interesting as
Stannis's plan was originally to have a
positive impact on the universe but
clearly it hasn't I recently did a video
discussing why Thanos failed which would
be linked at the end and in that i
theorize that due to plant insect and
animal life being killed the planet
would be on the brink of collapse it's
clear now that this is the case and
another notable line from the synopsis
is the Avengers must assemble once more
in order to undo the narces actions and
restore order to the universe once and
for all no matter what consequences may
be install fans have theorized for a
while that time travel will be used in
the film and it's clear that there will
be a reversal of Thanos his actions that
no matter what consequences may be
install part stands out to me and
definitely confirms that we will get
some big debts in the film obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the news
and if you're excited for the film make
sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of why Thanos failed which
would be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]